بعد ما يقرب العام على الحرب في اوكرانيا
تقترب الحرب هناك اكثر فاكثر من استخدام
الروبوتات القاتله لحسم المعركه وفقا طبعا
لخبراء عسكريين تحدثوا لي السوشيت بريس
الروبوتات القتاليه تؤسس
لثوره عميقه في التكنولوجيا العسكريه ما
يجعل الحروب اكثر دمويه لانها تقضي على
البشر
وتجعل التحكم في العمليات اكثر وتستند الى
احداثيات وتحليلات سابقه للعمليات
الهجوميه المحتمله ولكن ماذا عن هذا مش
الخطا هذا الهامش يظل كبيرا وهو ما يدفع
الخبراء العسكريين للدعوه الى تقييد
العمليات الهجوميه المعتمده على ذكاء
الاصطناعي تقدم الطائرات المسيره في
اوكرانيا وتتقدم من الجانبين الروسي
والاوكراني مما ادى الى تسريع الاتجاه
التكنولوجيا الذي طال انتظاره حيث يمكن ان
يجلب قريبا اول روبوتات قتاليه مستقل
الكامل في العالم الى ساحه المعركه ويطلق
عصرا جديدا من الحروب يقول طبعا هنا
الخبراء ايضا يمكن لي الطائرات مشاهدينا
من دون طيار بالفعل التعرف على اهداف مثل
المركبات والمدرعات باستخدام الصور
المفهرسه كما نشاهد هنا ولكن الخلاف
متواصل حول ما اذا كانت التكنولوجيا
موثوقه بدرجه كافيه لضمان عدم ارتكاب
الالات الخطا والفتك بغير المقاتلين
لاوكرانيا بالفعل طائرات هجوميه من دون
طيار شبه مستقله واسلحه مضاده للتكنولوجيا
مزوده بالذكاء الاصطناعي الطائرات القاتله
ذاتيه التحكم بالكامل هي خطوه ثانيه
منطقيه وحتميه في تطوير الاسلحه في
اوكرانيا ويمكن طبعا اللجوء اليها في سته
اشهر المقبله كما اكد وزير التحول الرقمي
الاوكراني سابقا بالنسبه لروسيا ليعتبر
الذكاء الاصطناعي اولويه حيث اعلن الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان من يسيطر على
هذه التكنولوجيا سيحكم العالم